so this is a compound called per hydro
histrionic toxin very difficult see
actually it's just a tiny speck in there
probably less than a milligram of this
compound in this style and yet that'll
be enough easily to kill a human being
so it's an incredibly toxic out of the
the nature's chemical warfare frogs have
evolved all sorts of mechanisms to
defend against predators and birds and
what-have-you so this is one of the
compounds like they can excrete when
they're under attack so on the surface
of the frog you get this gooey excretion
if it's under attack it looks like a
white foamy substance and these are only
frogs which usually found in Latin
America things on there are endangered
species so we're not allowed one but
here's my model of one but actually
though they're even smaller than this so
the frogs you get over in this country
are fairly sizable these frogs are
probably about the size of your
thumbnail very very tiny very brightly
colored so this one's blue but this is
no an ear as bright as some of these
frogs that's reds and yellows it's
essentially screaming danger so when the
the birds comes in
it may be packet is cut the Frog needs
something to act really quickly and over
the millions of years they've developed
these compounds and they actually act on
the nervous system so like what they do
is they paralyze the bird instantly so
the bird is one minute about to have
dinner
the next minute is completely frozen
like a statue and of course the frog can
hop away the bird eventually dies of
asphyxiation because it the lungs it all
the breathing all those muscles
everything gets paralyzed or go back to
this again so it's probably just less
than one milligram in here and you can
you can't see it it's so small smell a
speck of dust sort of size about three
milligrams were first isolated from
1,100 frogs so you can see that these
things these compounds are so potent
that the frogs really don't need to make
very much of this in all
to be effective in their defense of the
against you know multiple progresses
when the Spanish in others French went
out to the South America hundreds of
years ago now when they were exploring
of course say they turned up and I
thought well the native people here just
have bows and arrows or Spears these
guys will be a walkover but of course
they won't because well they had with
poison darts so sometimes these frogs
are called poison dart frogs or poison
arrow frogs so what they would do that
they would capture these frogs and these
frogs only make this toxin when they're
in the natural environment if you have
them in captivity they don't have the
right diet resource I can't make these
molecules so these native Indians would
go and they would keep them in a hollow
tube and when they needed them they
would take a spear or a dart and they'll
put it down the mouth of the Frog to the
other end to its leg and oddly enough
that would make the Frog sweat quite a
bit and you'll get all this white gooey
excretion coming from the skin and you
just take your arrows and you just swirl
it around in this secretion and these
arrows then would be poisonous for
around about a year so this these
compounds are quite stable entities
quite stable compounds and of course
what happened was the invaders came over
and of course when they got shot with
these darts or Spears with this poison
on the tip they would be paralyzed just
like the bird just like anything else so
it birds are quite small humans are
quite big still sub milligram quantities
of this material is enough to paralyze
indeed kill a human being so these are
very potent compounds right well you can
get it from frogs but if you remember I
said 1,100 frogs will give you about 3
milligrams of this material we wanted to
make these compounds in a synthetically
viable way so you could make grams if
you needed to to allow these further
studies to go on these could also be
potentially useful compounds
for the treatment of pain maybe in the
future certainly good lead compounds for
study because pain messages you also go
through the nervous system so this is
this is this particular one molecule
here so this is per hydro hysteretic a
toxin and it's actually this is a
synthetic compound so there's about
fifteen of these compounds and it's just
these two side chains which are
different this core structure in the
middle is always the same that the blue
one here that's nitrogen this is a
oxygen so this is a hydroxyl function
here and it's the combination of these
two and the exact spacing between these
two which is key to why this molecule
work so this mimics a natural
neurotransmitter use to convey the
message between two parts of the nervous
system so you can think of a nervous
system is an electrical cable and then
you'll get a connector junction so
imagine that two connectors coming
together a plug in a socket now this the
acetylcholine molecule transmits from
the plug to the socket the spacing of
these two functionalities here is
absolutely key so these fit the key that
acetylcholine normally would fit in to
trigger the response if you are clumsy
or indeed if you got shot by a poison
arrow this gets into your bloodstream it
can get immediately to the peripheral
nervous system so that's all your
muscles your hearts your lungs anything
that moves in your body and it can block
the receptors in those or block the the
signals from your brain to your lungs
for example to tell it to breathe in and
out now you don't consciously think that
you're doing that but your brain is a
very clever thing it sets so many things
on autopilot but it's constantly sending
out messages many
many hundreds a second to control what's
going on in your body and this little
molecule here and it would take just a
few of these molecules to completely
shut down those muscular neuro
transmissions if you like if it got into
your central nervous system in your
spine in your brain it could completely
wipe out any messages that are coming
from your hands from any senses to your
brain so in many ways that's why it
could be very useful for pain management